for my project I'm basically trying to
model one of the experimental techniques
in biology known as molecular cloning so
the idea is that you take one gene from
one organism and put it inside the other
host organism however the problem is
where do you actually put in that Gene
right do you put it at side a or side B
and you want the regions of insertions
that are minimally distructive to the
actual host um and so I'm developing an
algorithm based on like a few metrics so
for example the side that you're going
to be inserting at should not be inside
any of the host gene or the side that
you're inserting at should be maximally
far away from other genes or the region
that you're inserting at should be the
least similar from all other parts of
the genome and so I'm basically writing
that algorithm writing that in Python
and then I'm also experimentally
validating it so I finished developing
the algorithm and now I have all the
list of the sites for eoli for
integration and so we picked the five
top sides and the five bottom sides and
we're doing um experimental Integrations
to see whether our technique actually
works or not and based on that we're
going to refine our
algorithm